gersón está cambiando de color desde la
liberación de la ciudad los ucranianos
han derribado las vallas de propaganda
rusas rojas blancas y Azules y las han
sustituido por mensajes patrióticos en
azul y dorado de Ucrania este dice
compatriotas son libres
[Aplausos]
estos cambios visuales son realmente
importantes porque durante la ocupación
los rusos utilizaron las vallas
publicitarias para imponer sus mensajes
a la población
querían demostrar su presencia lo veías
en la televisión y en sus vallas
publicitarias que estaban por todas
partes
eso creaba mucha presión psicológica
sobre la gente
una valla publicitaria aborda otro
problema ahora que la ciudad está
liberada la desusificación adopta muchas
formas incluida la casa de colaboradores
o traidores como los llama este cartel
que tengo detrás mío mediante este
código de barras puede ponerse en
contacto con una organización de
investigación que recopila información
para su publicación el coordinador
Regional de chesno como se llama la
organización es sherig miquitenco
periodista de investigación
la cantidad de datos que tenemos es
enorme no solo hablamos de colaboradores
de los territorios temporalmente
ocupados sino también de periodistas
propagandistas que intentan blanquear su
reputación estamos obteniendo resultados
dice que no no trabaja directamente con
las autoridades pero sus objetivos
coinciden a menudo
Alexander es un operador de las fuerzas
especiales también se dedica a cazar
colaboradores
sabemos que los rusos crearon listas de
directores y profesores de escuelas de
gerson dispuestos a colaborar con sus
autoridades
pero la mayoría de esos maestros huyeron
a territorio controlado por Ucrania por
lo que los rusos empezaron a traer
profesores de Rusia y crimea y tacos
pero Alexander no siente ninguna
simpatía por los que cayeron en la
tentación de colaborar con los rusos hay
que perseguirlos dice y castigar